and i think now people are so afraid to
even play with dangerous ideas because
they can just immediately be cancelled
or written off that it's like
we're not gonna get to like the good
dialogue that's supposed to come
high breath all right hot breath the
verse welcome back to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros today's guest has a comedy special
coming out on august 4th right
there on the one and only netflix and
welcome to
the hot breath verse the one and only
sam jay everyone let's give a round of
applause for sam jay
what's going on y'all whoo there's
there's an applause sound effect
happening right now don't worry
okay thanks so well i'm
we're super excited to have you on the
show um i'm super excited just because
of
i'm not only a fan but just of like your
journey
and not only just like just the
hardships you've overcome but just your
self-made success and comedy from
i mean you started the first time you
tried it was at 20 and then you didn't
try it again until 29
so now you're about to release an
hour-long netflix special so how long
have you been doing comedy between your
uh the second time you tried it and now
probably eight years eight years
that's incredible yeah so
wow like what are you um what do you
what do you attribute to i mean because
i'm i'm 10 years in to stand up
and hearing like you know i've had
friends that book like conan five years
in you're like wow that's so fast but
you have done
so many things in just like a short
amount of eight years like what do you
attribute to like
besides raw talent of course but what do
you attribute to like that success
um i don't know i think it was just
timing i think is very important and not
in the sense of
the timing of the industry just like
as corny as it sounds like timing for
yourself like
when you're truly ready for something
and you're walking in your
you'll see the universe kind of
aligned with you
you know what i'm saying and things seem
to give you less
resistance when you finally like really
figure out
and work out all this inner stuff and
kind of align with your purpose
so i think you know some of it is is
just purely that
you know like it was just growth and
and also i just think being older i
started
i was you know 20 but then stopping i
picked it up until i was 29 i really
knew myself
and i had enough life experiences that i
wanted to share
i think a lot of times the time that
they say comedy takes is not
time in comedy per se as much as it's
just
time you need to grow as a person and
kind of like
develop a voice which is really just
life experience and then that's how you
relate those life experiences and
when you're young you just really
haven't had many yet most of us haven't
you know
so i think that also played a huge part
in it was just my age i
i i wasn't i think sometimes people
start comedy
just for a social group i didn't start
comedy for friends you know i was grown
i had my friends i really
started it to like achieve something and
so i was
super focused in that way and didn't
spend a lot of my time
spinning my wheels but that also came
from life experience and
you know venturing out and doing other
things and so that taught me what
spinning your wheels looks like
so i was able to recognize those spaces
a lot
sooner and and that's move move on from
them
you know so i think all of that kind of
is why
how are you able to recognize when
you're just spinning your wheels
i mean i think it's just it's it it will
constantly change
and it's if the thing is meeting your
goals i think having goals is so
important because then you thing you can
assess is this thing
meeting and serving the need that i have
right now you know
and that changes when i first started i
just needed stage time
that's all i needed it didn't matter how
much that's all i needed
but i had to recognize when my i was
growing past
just needing stage time and i needed
quality stage time and so
i just start to make some choices of
like nah i'm not just gonna go
spin my wheels in this direction i could
go do three open mics tonight or i could
sit
at this one show that's gonna give me
quality stage time and build a
relationship
and what's actually going to serve me is
doing this
and not chasing my tail at these mics
because now i got these bits that
i need time to to build them and i can't
do that at a three minute mic
it just is not possible i need to be
like for me
how i do stand up i need to sit in this
i need to be able to
you know dissect this for a while before
i'm gonna land on really what it is and
like
in order to do that i need space and
time so it's just like you know
being aware of what i was trying to
achieve helped me
decide where i was going to put my
energy yeah and that's something that's
super unique to your journey is that you
actually
had a stint in doing artist management
for musicians and
like planning out a career like being
structured what kind of
tips do you have for comedians that are
struggling to
plan out a career where do we start and
then how do we start to piece it
together
i think one you just have to look at
like
careers that you
like in comedy i think i did that to
some degree i
i looked at trajectories that i was like
oh that looks like
the kind of way i want to do it to some
degree and i
looked at what the they did like
that simply and then kind of started
setting benchmarks and goals for myself
to get me into those into that direction
and like you'll actually write down
these goals do you do a vision board
a little bit of both i mean but i think
it's whatever like works for you i don't
think there's any one way to do it when
i first started i had a
notebook journal thing and i would write
goals
at it and i needed that when i first
started i needed to write it down i
needed that level of like structure
and also commitment because it was the
first time i was really like throwing
myself into something and i think
writing it down was just another level
of committing to it for me
but now that i'm like i don't do i still
set goals but i don't feel the need to
write them down or anything i just have
them in my head and i kind of like
know what i'm pushing towards so i think
it just that also changes and it's kind
of what works for you
how important are the comedians you
surround yourself with also
because a lot of times out of this open
mic grind we can get caught up and like
well they're at these show and we're all
kind of on the grind but is it
important to surround yourself with
ambitious comics and not get pulled down
but as opposed to like rise up type deal
i think that's a general thing with
people you know what i mean i think that
like you should you know try to surround
yourself with
with it's like it's like a double-sided
thing it's like like-minded people and
like-minded not in a sense they think
like you but like-minded innocence of
like
they have the same heart as you they
they value things
the way you value things but i also
think people that at the same time think
differently to you and will challenge
you
and i think it's like finding that type
of balance of like people
for sure well will help a hundred
percent i think if you're hanging around
a bunch of people that are just kind of
like doing it for the of it
and and you know it's more of a like
hang in a boys club to them and you're
super serious about it that's probably
not a good
mix and in thinking of
just like your trajectory and you being
a writer on snl
like what you didn't even have sketch
writing experience
before getting hired onto snl
correct well i'm not i'm not the first
oh really to not like have sketch right
experience we get hired as a writer
oh interesting oh i didn't realize
that's how the game was over there
sometimes the game over there is what's
gonna work best to make the best show
and that takes a mix of people and a mix
of backgrounds and a mix of experiences
and uh you can you know it's a comedy
centered show
so as long as you got funny and they
feel like it can work within the system
then
you may have an opportunity in that
space
oh so did you just like know someone
there that referred you is that how you
get hired without
what uh how do you get into writing for
snl without like
like sketch writing experience you work
hard you do a lot of stand up you get
seen people start talking about you
you know there's no there's no left to
this it's just doing the work
and the doors that are supposed to open
for you will open for you
and you must have like had to go through
like a sketch writing like
crash course and this is one of the
questions that came up
from um one of the people uh people
watching live this is cedric
drake and he asked like how does being a
stand-up help you write sketches and
maybe you could also
incorporate what did you learn about
sketch writing that you could share with
stand-ups that are interested in getting
into it
uh i think stand-up just helps you
have a point of view and that will help
you with anything that you're
doing and so i guess that's how it
applied to the world
of sketches um and what was the second
part of the question
i'm sorry oh just like um you clearly
had to learn a lot
very quickly about sketch writing so
what what are kind of the
the things that have helped you to write
better sketches faster
um i think it's just like i had to get
outside of myself i think as a stand-up
you're writing for yourself
and you're writing your voice and when
you first start to write sketch you
write as if everybody's in your head
and they get this the the little nuances
that are going on
and people don't and they're not and i
had to kind of learn
how to put that on paper without
also dragging the sketch down or
or slowing it down but just learning how
to like be
a more colorful i guess in
in the in the writing and also a little
sillier
it taught me silly which i think helped
me tremendously and it was something
that i felt
i was struggling with on stage and like
i know i'm
funny but i feel like i felt like
sometimes i was
being more poignant than i was just
being in the moment and i
i was like ah i don't i don't want to
not have that silly fun part of it
and you know i don't think that part
would have grown
without learning how to break all my own
rules
in the sketch world and just being like
oh this thing could just
be dumb for the sake of being dumb and
just funny for the sake of being funny
and when i kind of got in my out of my
own way in that way and stopped
always kind of thinking like what's the
point of this sketch and just started
thinking like what's the fun of this
sketch what makes me laugh
then the rest kind of grew uh and
mitt wolff asks um do you have a
favorite sketch
and how was it written um
do i have a favorite skit
hmm maybe my favorite sketch was a
sketch with uh
adam driver where they're at like the
the white
uh meeting and he keeps saying that they
can go to vermont
and and live in the white utopia that
they they keep saying they want to live
in
um and that just came because me and
tucker
were were talking and he was talking
about how he just came from vermont and
it was like this
and i was like oh dude i used to have a
joke where i was like
the new england is the last like white
haven like if if you just want to go
and just be white and not be bothered
like there's still a place for you
and we just started riffing and laughing
about it honestly
is that how a lot of the sketches come
up is like through conversation that
then sparks an idea to sketch
yeah i mean it's it's a creative space
so it works like creative spaces work
in that regard yeah we have a few people
asking about
writer's block as well so this this
could go with sketch writing or with
your stand-up like
how do you overcome writer's block how
do you deal with that
uh i don't know like
i i just hm if i'm being honest i don't
really
i haven't really gone through that yet
because i try to write
in the directions that i'm inspired to
write i don't
i'm just not a person that believes in
that super structured
format so i'm not like a i'm not a comic
that gets up and it's like i gotta write
five jokes a day i don't do that i don't
write five jokes a day
i i'm i'm kind of always constantly
experiencing things and thinking about
things and
you know pondering on things so it's
like i don't know i feel like i'm
always kind of writing and i just write
the things that
inspire me and and if it's not
inspiring me then i kind of like shelf
it mentally
and go like maybe this will spark
something at another point or maybe
it won't or maybe it will add to an idea
later
you know but i i just find when you try
to
force it it feels forced do you
attribute that to like that is something
i admire and love about your standup is
it is so authentic
it's so vulnerable and it is seeming
that like
how you talk on stage is how you would
talk offstage and bridging that gap can
take like decades for some comics so is
that what you attribute to being able to
sound so organic on stage
um i just never wanted it to feel forced
i just never wanted it to feel like i
was trying to put on a suit that didn't
fit me
and so i try to make this stuff for me
feel as me
as it can feel because i feel like
that's the i can get behind
and that stuff i can live and die by but
when i
start trying to be something if
even if it like it i always put it like
this like i never want to
try to be something and fail not doing
my own thing because
it's the worst type of failure and and
i've been there you know when i first
started stand up i thought i had to
do it a certain way and then like
with bomb
and i hated myself because i'm like
that's not even how you would say it
that's not even
how you wanted to do this so it's like
now you failed
and you and you wasn't even you so like
you double lost
whereas like damn i just got to a place
where i was i'd rather just
shoot my shot and at least if i
break
it was still my shot you know what i
mean because the bottom line is like
you can break it it happens it's not
it's an unavoidable thing so it's like
once you get that fear out of your head
of like if you're gonna do this for
a long time you're gonna bomb mad times
you know it's gonna
you just gonna miss it's just no way
this is no way
so it's almost like the more you bomb
the less fear you'll end up having
yeah it's a part of the process i don't
trust a comic who says they've never
bombed
yeah they never like tried you never got
vulnerable
you never was really up there what is
what is your worst bomb like have you
ever been booed or is there a situation
like what is the worst bomb you've had
in your career so far
honestly i've never bombed before now
that you think of it
i definitely bomb but i kind of like put
that immediately out my head
i don't even like i don't even sit in
that too long so like
they all kind of run together like i
can't be like yo there's one time and
i think they're all just like one thing
when i first started i remember going
to do this show with a guy named
jonathan gates and he was doing all the
black shows in the city and
and i went and on the road with him and
i bombed really bad i don't remember
where we were we were somewhere like
we might have been in ohio and i bombed
real bad real bad in this room full of
black people like
bad like crickets nothing like nothing
like nothing
like nothing went over nothing not one
joke
not one nothing worked like i only have
to have one moment of like
were they kind of like this so i could
work with that it was just like none of
this is
flying just literally talking to like
stone faces for like 30 minutes
i was featuring 30 minutes yeah i bombed
for 30 minutes
and that's probably like the one that
sticks out to me but i can't guarantee
you that was worse i probably bombed
worse than that
and just pushed it out my head but
that's the one that i remember because
that was the one
where i i learned a lesson i guess so it
stuck in my head and
the lesson that i learned was like
to be in the moment like you can't just
come up there with your agenda because
you you having a conversation with
people
and just be more in the moment and
recognize when it isn't working
and be free to switch up in your
way
and i and i felt like when i went up
there i was just
driving the car and i was like you know
it's going this way
and they was like we not going that way
and i was like look this is where i'm
going and i didn't try to pivot at all
so
it just taught me the the the lesson
like it's okay to pivot a little bit
to open them up and then like you could
swoop the car back around and bring them
back
where you was going you don't have to
not go where you was going but sometimes
you might have to take a little
detour to get them on board so that you
can bring them to the destination
yeah i heard you talking about in an
interview on another podcast about
performing in the uk
and the res they just don't laugh as
loud over there and you were actually
like
got out of the set and we're just like
talking to them like so why don't y'all
laugh
that much you're like what's almost like
addressing them authentically
kind of like creates a more i guess it
seems like more
nurturing and relationship with the
audience
i don't know if it's nurturing i just
know that i can't do stand up like that
it's got it so that's gotta be real it
feels
wild if i'm standing in a room full of
people and i feel the energy and i don't
recognize it
and i act like it's not going on then
the rest of this won't work for me
perfect that's good to know yeah being
aware on stage and if something is off
addressing it because probably everyone
in the room is thinking the same thing
right and one of the one of the jokes
you attribute to like having kind of
like a breakthrough
in the direction of your writing is your
madman bit
which is which is absolutely hilarious
was on your comedy central special
but like what is it about that bit that
really kind of because we were talking
to kyle kanan last week and he had a
similar bit
not about mad men but where he was like
oh this is the direction i want to take
my comedy so what was it about that mad
men bit that kind of almost like opened
up
a new realm for you i i think it was
just because it was a
it was a it was a difficult thought for
me
like i pondered the the thought process
for a while and couldn't figure out an
angle
into it that felt right and felt like
saying all the things i wanted to say
in the way that i wanted to say him it's
it's layered in the way that i like
comedy where it's a little tricky
you know i mean if you listen to it on
one level you'll get one thing but if
you
listen to it on a second level you'll
get another layer like it has
bottom which i like in jokes and um
it was just the first time i had
successfully like strung all the things
together and and it was like and it was
like a stretch
of a bit it wasn't like this like fast
paced thing i was also like taking my
time
and people were uncomfortable but i
wasn't running from their comfortability
because i
i was confident where the end was and so
that it was the first time i was like oh
okay yeah this is how you want to
like
do it almost like slowing down
adds new power to the joke
i think it depends on the joke well yeah
okay it can
yeah cause that's um and someone's
asking um
let's see yeah i love that um i love you
saying it has new layers to it so do you
almost like look for that in
jokes of like it the good ones are gonna
have like these
types of criteria to really fulfill
i just know it when i feel it i know
what i'm saying it and i'm like yeah
it's doing this stuff you know what i
mean i don't know if i like
i probably am subconsciously doing that
but i'm just not aware of it but
probably i am doing that to some degree
but i i just
know when i'm doing it how it feels
and how it's connecting and like i know
when i'm
saying all the things i want to say you
know and i know when sometimes when the
joke first starts it's like
it's very just one direction because
that's like
it's the first time i'm pulling it apart
and so the first way i look at things is
usually from a
me centric space then second wave of it
is like
how do people feel about it outside of
me
and then the third wave of it is kind of
looking above it all
how i'm reacting to it and how they're
also reacting to it so it's like
that's that's just a natural though like
process i think when you just are
dissecting anything it's like you
usually come from you first
and then if you keep pondering on it
you'll start to think about it from all
the other angles
but that's a that's a good system to
have though in terms of like okay how do
i feel about this and then you kind of
go through the different layers of it
like that that's
that's gold
and you being vulnerable on stage is
something that it
it's seeming you make it sound so easy
to make it look so easy but like
for for like a comic struggling to be
more authentic on stage do you have any
tips for how we can start to
really get stuck okay
it's just fear you have to stop caring
if they like you and you have to realize
that they're
all not they're gonna like you sometimes
they're just not gonna like you
it's still just people meeting people
and everybody don't like you and that's
fine
cool all right um another
got another question here about uh
writing
for snl uh like what are the
it's it's a dream job it sounds like but
what are
some of the um stressful parts about
writing for a big network like snl
i mean it's still just a job at the end
of the day you know like
you go in every day it becomes work and
like work
is stressful because it's work and it
has deadlines and it has demands
and you're fulfilling someone else's
needs
at the end of the day and like not your
own
and so like in all those ways it's
stressful like a job
and what is uh what does your day-to-day
look like what is like the job aspect of
writing at snl
i mean you're writing most of the time
and then when you're when you're not
writing you're you're
you're you're helping make sketches
better punching things up
any like it's a very collaborative space
you know like
we we could be watching someone's sketch
and just notice that the the backdrop is
is wrinkly and be like hey i was
watching your sketch and they
they kind of up the backdrop yo
you might want to tell them you know
what i'm saying before
before the goes live because at the
end of the day a good show for one
person is a good show for everybody
and um lockheed is asking
how is sketch different from stand up
and maybe which ways are they similar
uh i mean it's different because it's a
different part of your brain
you know like you're casting people
you're you're assigning roles to
other people you know you write a sketch
you gotta cast it you gotta say who's
saying what
and so you're using another part of like
your brain to
to do all that stuff and it's another
part of your comedic mind
in a sense where stand up is just
youth-centric you don't have to worry
about any of that you're just saying
what you think jody followed up with
uh jody carter asking what is uh
seems like a lot of people in this group
were excited because they were looking
to learn about
sketch writing more so like what is
something a beginner needs to know about
sketch writing that they may not expect
um
let me think back to something that was
like a lesson like a moment
i think the one thing i i learned is
this the thing i said
previously which is just like
nobody's in your head
so you have to kind of write like
they're not in your head i think people
write with assumption a lot
like oh they know what i mean by that
they don't know what you mean by that
you can't assume that they do know what
you mean by that or that they know
what this action is supposed to
inference you know what i mean they
don't
so and and also and stand up when you
make those mistakes because it's a live
thing like
you can pivot like i said
and in sketch there is no pivoting what
you write on the paper
is what is written
for better or worse sometimes i would
imagine
because you are on those train tracks
there's no veering off like okay you all
aren't laughing that loud let's talk
about it
ah you can't do that yeah that's
there's an opportunity for that you know
have you had a sketch like that was in
dress rehearsal and then it had to be
rewritten or like something like
adjusted really quick yeah all the time
yeah that's just that's just a part of
show you i might have to rewrite
something just for time
reasons it's awesome i mean it's a live
stream so
you know you might have to change it up
just because we're running out of time
do you have do you have a favorite uh
guest or memory from working at snl
i mean eddie murphy guest and
oh sure gosh wha what was that like
surreal i'm just crazy there's no way to
really put words around it it's just
like
you just feel like whoa how am i here at
this moment it's just
crazy so did you like get to talk to him
or be
you have to talk to everybody you work
there they're we're all working
of course of course so we got to talk to
each other there's no way around that
uh so what what was he like i see you're
you seem to be hesitant about talking
about getting to work with eddie murphy
here a little bit
i mean i don't like to talk about what
people are like because what they like
is what they would like to mean
you know what i'm saying but he was he
was cool yeah it was a cool experience
i i really i was i was in awe most of
the time
because you're just watching a legend do
his thing and also in a space that he
hasn't been in
in a very long time you know what i'm
saying so it was just like whoa this is
like i said it's surreal that's the only
real word to put to it it was just like
walking through a dream for a week where
everybody was just kind of like
i can't believe this is happening and
what did you learn from him just even by
observing
how he operated what'd you learn nothing
nothing i i wasn't trying to learn
anything i was just happy to be
observing
okay how he operates i don't know if i
learned anything or if whatever i
learned hasn't even
downloaded onto me yet you know what i
mean but i didn't walk out of it
with a like yup this is how it'd be the
most i walked out of it was just like
if i learned anything it's like you
gotta keep
it's just still like we're all just
creating and it's still just like
work for everybody and it's like you got
to work at it you know
like he was still working hard and he
still cared about
this coming off right and he was
still like invested in his performance
and you could see like
he was really giving a and it's
like he wasn't just walking around like
i'm eddie murphy this is all gonna be
great
he was still like we gotta make sure
this is great and i think like
you're always kind of that going to be
that you know i don't
it just showed me like you don't
graduate from that if you are great
there it is i'm glad we kept digging i
knew there was something in there
yeah you're getting to work with eddie
murphy you're like no it was cool you
know we're just chilling we were writing
you know it's just
but honestly this is the first time i've
even thought about it and dissected it
so
at first when you asked i really didn't
have the answer oh awesome well we uh we
really appreciate you sharing that with
us that's that's super valuable
um all right as we'll start to land this
plane here
um i've got a question here from bob
jorgensen about
what is your opinion um the most
and least encouraging things about where
comedy is heading
uh i think the most encouraging thing is
the diversity
you know you see so many different
people and that's always
good to see i think the least
is people
i just think like and i don't want to
say cancel culture because it's not
cancelled culture as much as it's just
people yeah comcast culture like people
aren't
forgiving which makes people fearful to
explore ideas and it's like
a lot of this is also growth and you
have to let
you know i mean like the thing i think
this week i might tell a joke
this week and in three months i don't
even believe that so i'll stop telling
the joke i got a new perspective so the
joke has grown and the joke has does
change
and i think now people are so afraid to
even play with dangerous
ideas because they can just immediately
be cancelled or written off that it's
like
we're not gonna get to like the good
dialogue that's supposed to come
do you see that shifting or getting
worse or
i don't know i don't know what i see it
doing i just
i'm aware it exists i feel it in the air
but i don't know
you know i can't give it a metric in
that way
is there anything in your news special
that was it started out as kind of like
ah this could go either way but then you
kind of worked it out to
be a little more like digestible
topics you cover and things so i mean i
think that's
like the whole thing you know what i
mean it's like
you're riding from one space and you're
just trying to you're trying to figure
out how like
how to get the medicine to taste good to
everybody you know what i'm saying so
i think a lot of it felt that way in
that sense
yeah how do you because i feel like i've
had some jokes
uh where they start out they didn't
necessarily start
as funny but i was getting some sort of
reaction so i kept
like digging deeper to find what's funny
about it is that kind of how you
dive into those deeper topics you're
like well it's getting some connection
and then i'll start to
finesse it in the funny yeah 100
cool awesome all right
so in closing here um first off if you
could i mean i love that you filmed uh
the special here
in atlanta i'm actually based in atlanta
i know you were born in college park but
started comedy in boston but um
glad you brought it back to the atl um
do you do you have anything i mean the
special comes out august 4th
i think it's called three in the morning
is that correct
like what is what's the origin of that
is that part of a bit that we'll see
inside of it
no it's just no
it doesn't ever come up again actually
i love it it seems like you really just
honed in on
following your instincts and following
like it seems like following your heart
and following the feeling around making
decisions
i mean is that yeah i mean why else do
it yeah
you know it's not a it's not a nine to
five it's no guaranteed money
there's no real security so you kind of
like if you're playing this game you
playing because you want to shoot
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
[Music]
today